all right let's be honest there's always  plenty of trouble in paradise for a  bachelor nation but that's not always  the case for some of our favorite  couples so we teamed up with secrets  resorts and spas to take them away for a  week of unlimited luxury now this is  paradise guys welcome to secrets divine  Cancun let's Cheers  how does it feel to be back in Mexico  without the drama to worry about anyone  getting in our way let's start off with  a wine tasting let's do it  Armando how many of different wines you  have in a cellar here we have more than  400 labels in more than 2000 bottles  having been married having a beautiful  baby what kind of wedded advice are you  giving these two have babies because  they're the best yeah we're gonna wait  till after the wedding  whoa hey very nice wine can you check  out that new ah the bedroom where it all  happens if this view babe look at the  bathtub okay we have got to check out  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]